but hey i am going to get started on
this this is so cool
hey if you have your aging parents
living with you if you yourself have
heart disease
there's a brand spanking new procedure
to help treat advanced heart disease
folks it's called
lithotripsy you're like wait i've heard
of this before right don't worry about
it we'll explain
uh the physician who is safely doing it
he's already done it
it modifies the calcified plaque that
restricts blood flow to the heart you
know you've heard of these procedures
before
well joining me now is the first doctor
to perform it right here in the state of
nevada and i know him
yeah baby good morning dr karthik narala
yes you've seen him here before he we
talk to each other he's like monica
there's this new procedure i think i'm
going to be the first one to do it in
the entire state i said let's book it
so here he is how you doing hey monica
good morning how are you
i am doing great let's get right into it
where and when did it all happen how's
the patient doing right now
um he's doing great actually uh it was
fda approved february 16th
um we were able to get it in the state
uh very quickly we
we did the procedure uh march 8th uh
patient uh did well it was done at saint
ross siena in henderson
and and he went home the very next day
okay so tell me about the procedure give
me a little detail dr narala
and why it's such a big deal because i
have heard of lithotripsy before
yeah and it's a technology that's been
around for decades
we used to use it as doctors in
patients that have had kidney stones and
so it's basically ultrasound
that will break up calcium in the kidney
stones and that used to
allow people to get rid of the stones
and now what they've done is basically
use that technology
to put it inside of a small small
balloon
and then that balloon is able to be put
into the heart into the arteries
and it um in arteries that have really
bad calcium buildup because that plaque
that builds up in the arteries has been
around for
ages it used to be that it was very hard
to get rid of that and we used to have
to use very strong drills and other
mechanisms to get rid of that but now
with this technology
you can put that same technology into
the heart into the artery
and you turn it on and it breaks up that
calcium so that you can
open up the rest of the vessel much
easier nice okay so is there a specific
group dr narala
that is most likely to need this
procedure again i was talking about you
know
our aging parents they're moving in with
us even before the pandemic hit
that there was a shift in the family
dynamic so our aging parents are moving
in
they're taking you know our my sister
right now
my parents live with her and she makes
sure that they get the health care that
they need there's been a shift so
what age group is most likely to need
this well it's usually
people that have had calcium and plaque
for a while so as plaque when it first
gets put into the arteries when it gets
starts building up as the arteries it's
very soft
and as the calcium builds up on the
plaque
the plaque becomes very hard so it's
definitely people that are
have had heart disease or may not even
know that they have had
heart disease but the plaque has been
slowly building up so it's not
uh this procedure is not for somebody
that has an emergent issue
um with a heart attack that we normally
see it's more of that that slow
chronic heart disease that's been around
for decades or maybe
five to ten years that has had a chance
to get calcium buildup on it
gotcha okay and i'm i'm just about out
of time but real quick tell me
how this procedure works in the age of
covet are there any extra measures
needed to be taken
as a result of it well at this time we
have a
strict uh policy with the hospitals
they're doing a very good job
of screening patients for covid
and um uh it's basically no
additional precautions other than the
ones that already exist
all right very good real quick yes or no
is it is it covered by insurance
oh yeah it's covered by insurance um if
it's a medical necessity you can use it
all right dr karthik narala thank you so
much we really appreciate it and thank
you ladies and gentlemen this was an
exclusive you're not going to hear it on
any other station
that's why it pays to watch mondays with
monica right here on eight news now good
day las vegas baby dr narala
thank you have a great rest of your week
all right hey folks
and don't forget to catch my moj show
facebook live tonight we're going to
replay that interview for you
and hey you know stay on top of this
sherry i was really excited to hear
about it because
i know heart disease number one killer
of men and women
in this country six hundred thousand
people die yearly from heart disease
that's crazy and he talks about it so
calmly it's just like
yeah this could save your life
absolutely it can and he's the first
doctor in the state to get well
that's awesome congratulations glad to
hear it is here
for us thank you monica